let's do this let me pull up uh
something a bit more political and then
we'll get into why this stuff is so
important
this is a story from the new york times
usa today to remove 23 articles after
investigation into fabricated sources
the articles were removed after
investigation identified stories of
sources that appeared to be fabricated
usa today said the internal
investigation which took place over a
period of several weeks began after usa
today received an inquiry related to the
veracity of details in an article by
gabriella miranda who was a breaking
news reporter at usa today all right
i'm going to pull up usa today real
quick
so one of the leading fact check news
organizations in the country has been
spreading false news and fake news for
and here's the best part
news guard gives them a 100 out of 100
wow
and they've been they've actually been
fabricating stories so my question to
newsguard is why did you certify an
organization that was fabricating
stories outright but tim they got it
they took them down now so they fact
check their own fact checks and
determine they were factually incorrect
so they get they should get a hundred
and one like uh
they're not fact checking there was just
gulagging they deleted
23 articles were deleted here's my point
new usa today publishes fake articles
newsguard looks at them and says those
are real why because usa today said so
usa is the fact check they fact check a
bunch of stuff that we say is bogus
fact-checking but you get called a
conspiracy theorist for calling up the
bogus fact checkers
okay i get fact-checked for the most
ridiculous stupidest things especially
when it comes to memes by these
institutions and and again another thing
to to kind of understand here go on
their website it should be front page
news on their website right now hey guys
we lied to you hey guys we fabricated
stories hey guys if this was me it is it
is it is it is it's january where it's
top headline yep there it is there it is
thank goodness all right good thank
goodness
finally uh but but it should have been
like so sorry we goofed up we messed up
we lied to you uh and this is full
transparency and accountability of what
actually happened but hold on if you
back it up just one second um i still
saw january 6th first i saw that too
that's not front page i mean they should
stop running news they should stop
putting out articles they should
apologize get on their knees to the
general public they said i'm so sorry i
lied to you but they don't that's what
anyone with any kind of reputation
should be doing right now because this
is so embarrassing and this is not
something that's uncommon this happens a
lot there's a lot of reporters doing
this brian williams another person who
did this uh very publicly this is why
free speech is so important
it's obvious i mean obviously free
speech is important for
a million and one reasons that we cannot
we talk about in terms of your right to
go outside and speak your mind or your
right to uh practice the the religion
you you want i'm speaking more broadly
than just the first amendment i mean
quite literally you're right to say
these things about what you believe and
uh on your politics but it's also
your ability to share the news on these
social media platforms and when the news
broke of censorship against
conservatives it was may of 2016 and it
was gizmodo i believe who said that
facebook
uh moderators for the trending tab were
deleting conservative sources from their
trending news section
because they believed conservative
sources were fake news
that was it
now we have news garden which is uh uh
one of their big clients i believe is
microsoft bill gates
and they they they like to certify or
these news outlets now i like i i like
it i like the idea and so we we i make
sure all of our sources are always going
to have that nice green check mark but i
will not hesitate to point out that
their system is completely broken and
makes no sense
particularly because
how does usa today have a 100 out of 100
if they are publishing fake news
how do fact checkers know whether or not
a story from music today is real or fake
if the new york times cnn or usa today
come out with a story and say
john smith told us he sold a boat for a
hundred dollars they would say it's true
because usa today said so
see that's not fact checking
they just say
these you know news guard for instance
totally biased in that we just assumed
usa today was right
no they should be down ranked completely
and they should be forced to jump
through hoops legal audits if they want
to get their green check mark back they
should be fired they shouldn't have a
job
well the reporter i think is getting
fired
the whole institution for allowing it in
my opinion well
the problem is there shouldn't be these
gatekeepers in the first place i mean
platforms shouldn't be gatekeepers they
shouldn't be labelers and that's where
rumble is taking the right direction
think about how irresponsible that is
like imagine putting a ceo of a tech
company to assign other companies or
other entities or other people to say
what's right or what's wrong like
what's true or or what's fiction i mean
you look at who am i to do that but it's
ridiculous it's the it's the circular
nature of it is that they they use their
own bill gates having any hand in this
whatsoever is already super sus as the
children say but they use these to
discredit the other independent voices
to then raise their own voices to
prominence so they can remove who's the
journalist it's like a version of
russiagate where you where you use your
own laundered information over and over
again as as sources and citations so you
have a bogus source come in and then
they leak to the press that the investor
fbi is investigating it and then they
use the press to get a fisa warrant and
then they use that fact to justify it to
congress there's a there's a list that
came out today of prominent people who
have sowed uh doubt about the election
now what does that mean to so doubt
about the election means nothing
literally nothing you could say
something like wow look at this story
about the election that's dumb and
they'll say oh but by sharing it you so
doubt whether i was in so i made the
list yeah i'm very excited but here's
the reason they do it
there are organizations that fundraise
off of this there are news outlets that
publish the lies
they need some kind of legal
justification so that i can't sue them
so someone will make an opinion
statement tim poole so doubt about the
election how did he do it he reported on
a new jury you knew a story in new
jersey about an election that had to be
redone due to them finding a bundle of
ballots in a mailbox true story
oh but that means tim poole is sowing
down on the election so we're gonna put
you on that list now news outlets can
all report the more extreme version they
can launder that information and say tim
poole
published or pushed lies
then when i come back and say that's not
true they'll say i was just referencing
this study and that was my
interpretation of it
good luck suing it's happening on a
smaller scale to me in canada but ctv w5
runs a story a hit piece on rumble
refers to it as a the darling of the
right wingers where you go to post
covert misinformation they then demonize
me on that show to make me look like i'm
responsible for one cherry picked uh
let's call it a bad comment
the story goes uh publishes wikipedia
then i noticed some people editing over
my wikipedia to say it's time we get
real with viva's right-wing extremism w5
showcased him and then i noticed another
article from the simon fraser institute
talking about disinformation on the
internet that google doesn't
auto-complete when you look up alex
jones it says author and not conspiracy
theorist and they think that's a problem
and i was in the appendix that when you
look up viva fry it doesn't say right
wing covered conspiracy theorist it just
says nothing
it's the wrap-up smear on a fake news
level i want to add to that real quick
so put it in that loop when google glass
came out it was very it was it was very
prominent because you could say you know
okay google tell me this and it would
talk to you you'd say
what is the capital of uh new york the
capital of new york is albany and then
they'll give you some facts so we get
this thing and so you know i'm hanging
out loot and i go
okay google who is tim poole and it goes
tim poole is an award-winning journalist
from chicago illinois and then i go okay
google who is luke rudkowski and it just
literally goes conspiracy theorist
that's it i was going to make that point
i'm i'm happy that you did before me i
was going to say that well i was
originally going to say i think everyone
in this room has been slandered has been
attacked had the media just make up
stories about them i mean i had my name
run through the mud they were just
making stuff up out of just thin air but
but just let's let's think about this
story from usa today what would happen
if one of us did what usa today did what
would happen if an independent media
organization ran 23 fake stories that
they just totally made up we would not
be
we would we would we would be hearing
about this luke for years to come can i
pause you real quick
do you really think it was just 23
stories this is what we know from their
own independent audit this is like the
police investigating the police which is
questionable
there's a reason bill gates puts
hundreds of millions of dollars into
media companies there's a reason that
social media algorithms promote these
trusted news sources that lie about
almost every single thing and and i
think even elon musk made this point
today saying that predominantly almost
everything that the corporate media
tries to sell is is a lie not all of it
but a lot of most of it um and and i
think it's fair to say that especially
with the way that our society has been
abused and used by the special interests
that corporate media is just pr for the
ruling establishment and it's nothing
else and this is a perfect example of
how they play by a whole different set
of rules when we get criticized we get
slandered we get lied about and we get
attacked and vilified for trying to even
speak up against this bullcrap politico
is a really interesting organization i
don't understand how their newsguard
certified which which makes me question
newsguard itself
politico has we we've showed these
stories before they have numerous
stories contradicting their own
reporting
one story is from january of 2017 that
says uh something like you know ukraine
panics
uh assisting democrats in the 2016
election is backfiring or something to
that effect the argument the story was
basically that ukraine tried helping
clinton to stop trump and when trump won
it was bad news for him they then wrote
a few years later that is actually
russian disinformation that ukraine
helped the democrats and both stories
are still live on politico how could
how could you say look if that was the
only thing let's let's say out of the
other 500 000 stories or whatever on
that website they're all true and
correct but those two exist you'd
immediately have to say as a rating
agency you are being stripped of being a
credible agency because you have two
articles that acute that both say both
stories are false uh i'm gonna ask a
stupid question is new york times
newsguard certified oh 100 okay
there's still an article up there that
says he dreamed of being a capital
police officer then a group of pro-trump
mobsters killed him brian sicknick that
article is still up wow and
one of the books that robert has
recommended on our locals community uh
the gray lady winked you realize it's
it's not a one-off it's
institutionalized it's been this way for
the last 70 years they got it wrong on
the homolodor they got it wrong
hold up
i apologize they got it wrong on world
war ii they got it wrong on hiroshima
they got it wrong uh on the um the
palestinian boy that was that was killed
in the first intifada it's a history
it's a pattern it's not about
consistency it's about hierarchy it's
not a mistake it's just the way
that's it
the only thing is we're now able to fact
check and call it out real time and then
and then if we make one mistake we get
uh not not just blacklisted you'll get
de-platformed if anyone had done one of
these stories they would be d-platform
oh you'd be banned from google news
instantly they would never show your
website again
for the longest time this show didn't
appear on google search it's the
craziest thing it's like we're on
youtube
then one day it was funny i called him
out on the show and then people were
like yo you're back on google like
someone watching at google was like
let's put them back in there and
loaded us back up
but it's remarkable that
google is the way people find
information
over 90 yeah you'll you'll go you'll you
open the browser bar and you type in
word i don't even type in web addresses
anymore i'll just type in you know like
what did i just do i typed in usa today
and press enter and then it went to
google
if google removed you said today for
being fake news wouldn't come up was a
very good suit against the bite
administration brought by the states of
arizona louisiana that goes through and
in their motion for preliminary
injunction details the degree of
government collusion that's been taking
place even under trump's administration
he didn't know his own department of
homeland security his own cyber
institute uh cyber security folks were
already manipulating information
including suppressing information
hostile to biden and favorable to trump
and they've only escalated that that's
why bobby kennedy's suit against
facebook is so important before the
ninth circuit court of appeals currently
pending but this has also been
government-created government-curated
censorship for the purposes of
controlling the information in the
narrative and that's why they fear big
tech and independent to any kind of
challenge to big tech monopoly is a
threat to their gatekeeping control over
the institutional narrative and they are
monopolies you characterize them
absolutely very correct for those people
out there that think monopoly means 100
it doesn't it means 75 or more
historically in american law and this is
over 80 google as you're mentioning over
90 of all searches controlled by google
almost all news information that sought
or see or that is read or reviewed or
heard is uh dominated by google but
robert responds to the argument that
people are going to say it's a
merit-based monopoly they've gotten it
because of a superior product none of
that's true the anti-trust litigation
details that i mean the there is some
degree that to which this technology
naturally inclines itself to monopoly in
the way peter thiel talks about but by
no means did they actually obtain this
monopoly twitter obtained it because
they said we're going to be the free
speech wing of the free speech party
they just lied that's what they did
that's what google did that's why
youtube lied youtube said hey we welcome
all content creators we're never gonna
censor anybody and they became one of
the biggest sensor sensors in the entire
game globe and they keep changing their
terms and services as you go along so
you agree to one you invest all of your
your time your energy your blood sweat
and tears into a business and then they
say you know what we're just going to
blacklist you because you
challenged the narrative you questioned
the agenda so we're going to demonetize
you down rank you and make sure that you
can't work on the internet at all which
is the power that they have which is
absolutely insane and way too much power
for one organization to have here's
here's where i think it's the most
important thing is i think for all of us
we've got platforms or literally run one
and so the problems we face are
particularly unique don't exist in the
general population
but for the average person who does
choose to get on twitter and say i would
like to speak my mind and challenge this
they're the ones who get banned first
when learn to code was happening when
they were banning people for for saying
hashtag learn to code majority of the
people who are getting banned were like
small counts people who were just you
know posting it the big channels were
less likely to get banned this is on
purpose they don't want to create a
splash but there are so many people i've
met and spoken with who say i can't i
went on i was on twitter for two days
and i posted a new story and they banned
me i hear it all the time now think
about what that means twitter will say
if they're on the left
give them some leeway if they're on the
right don't give them the time of day so
when right wing people come on or
libertarian moderate write whatever you
want to call it come on the platform and
say here's the real story with a link to
a source debunking something they're
banned instantly
if you ban 60 of them but only 40 of the
left if anyone at all you create this
lopsided system where the majority of
information coming out will be narrative
controlled fake news
and the people who know know better are
unable to counter it that's why we need
elon musk you're right over the target
with this one it's the long tail that
got banned that no one's talking about
it's the the people at the top they were
tougher to ban but the long tail really
got banned it shifted the whole system
tilted it everywhere this is why i think
this is why i think like platforms like
truth have a completely different
audience
you go ahead sorry no that that's that's
excuse perception and reality especially
if you're able to get rid of that tale
as you perfectly described here because
there has been a full frontal assault on
independent thought independent media
and critical thinking if you just go if
you dare to even just go against the
establishment and what they want you to
believe at that current time at that
current moment even though it flip-flops
by the interest whoever's involved in it
you are are done with you are not going
to have a way to succeed or live online
but now there's alternatives now there's
truth there's rumble there's getter
there's uh
hive there's steemit there's so many
other different alternative different
platforms out
there that's an old one i'm just i'm
just going off the train of thinking and
that's the old one that i remembered uh
there's there's hive there's so many
different ones out there it's also meant
to tell you as an independent person
that your view doesn't count that you've
your view is wrong so that little person
that ordinary person and everyday person
doesn't have lots of followers gets on
and has a distant information about
covet dissident information about the
election fornication that took place in
2020 has dissident information about
ukraine they're told your view is not
only disapproved not only unsanctioned
but it's wrong and nobody really agrees
with you and that's why you're being
censored that's why you're being
sanctioned that's why you're being
disapproved of and that's why it's
critical that there be tech challenges
to this whether it's locals whether it's
rumble whether it's true and i'll say
we're going to get into this with the
rumble terms of terms of use
discussion but the learn to code the the
rationale at the time if everyone
remembers it it was it was deemed
something of a call to violence it was
deemed to be harassment learn to code
for the journalists who mocked uh middle
america when they said well we're losing
our jobs and they said learn to code and
when the journalists started losing
their job they said learn to code oh
when we said it too it was loving you
know a a needle when you say it to us
it's a call to violence it's it's it's
weaponizing and bastardizing the terms
for political purposes thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there
you